...
-Tous les garçons et les filles
de mon âge se promènent..
..dans la rue deux par deux.
Tous les garçons et les filles
de mon âge savent bien..
..ce que c'est qu'être heureux.
Et les yeux dans les yeux...
Et la main dans la main...
Ils s'en vont amoureux..
..sans peur du lendemain.
Oui mais moi,
je vais seule par les rues,
..l'âme en peine.
Oui mais moi,
..je vais seule
car personne ne m'aime.
Mes jours comme mes nuits..
..sont en tous points pareils.
Sans joie et pleins d'ennuis.
Personne ne murmure "je t'aime"
à mon oreille.
Tous les garçons et les filles
de mon âge font ensemble..
..des projets d'avenir.
Tous les garçons et les filles
de mon âge savent très bien..
..ce qu'aimer veut dire.
Et les yeux dans les yeux...
Et la main dans la main...
Ils s'en vont amoureux..
..sans peur du lendemain.
Oui mais moi,
..je vais seule par les rues,
..l'âme en peine.
Oui mais moi,
..je vais seule..
..car personne ne m'aime.
Mes jours comme mes nuits..
..sont en tous points pareils.
Sans joie et pleins d'ennuis.
Quand pour moi..
..brillera le soleil.
Comme les garçons
et les filles de mon âge,
..connaîtrais-je bientôt
ce qu'est l'amour ?
Comme les garçons
et les filles de mon âge,
..je me demande
quand viendra le jour.
Où les yeux dans ses yeux...
Et la main dans sa main...
J'aurai le coeur heureux..
..sans peur du lendemain.
Le jour où je n'aurai..
..plus du tout..
..l'âme en peine.
Le jour où moi aussi..
..j'aurai quelqu'un..
..qui m'aime.